move over Derek Hough bindi Irwin got a  new dance partner oh man what you  talking about at least for one week ABC  has announced that next week is switch  up week on Dancing with the Stars and  all the celeb competitors will be  swapping pros bindi will be paired with  Val Chmerkovskiy Val's partner Tamar  Braxton is now as Louie van Amstel his  partner Paula Deen will be dancing with  Mark Ballas Oh Anna marks original  partner Alexa pano Vega will be dancing  with a derrick Alexa's husband Carlos is  learning from Lindsay Arnold and her  partner train hero Alek skarlatos is  with Emma Slater Emma's main man Hayes  Greer gets Allison Holker which means  Andy Grammer is now paired with Sharna  Burgess and Charnas partner Nick Carter  will be dancing with Whitney Carson who  normally dances with Carlos